foreign
if ever someone box at watching this
show because of its run time assure them
that the first 400 minutes are a
skippable introduction where vibrations
organize sand taking this dangerously
odd opportunity to stargaze well I guess
forever and always I will now scour the
silmarillion for the history of who
diapers the comet people and why
whatever face Nori's making it's a face
facing away from Poppy's face so how
does she know the face she's not facing
your mom's gonna kill you not if her
curiosity kills her first oh so that's a
strange thing to say after watching your
friend go through trauma how about try
are you all right next time because you
know there's going to be a Nori
Shenanigans next time I have any signs
do you need people who take astrology
seriously jeez malva's such a Libra
I don't care if you're a hobbit leader
don't snap your fingers at someone to
make them go faster it's rude and
irritating two sins for the lack of
manners jeez even though belly a
Sackville Baggins wouldn't do this on
her worst day oh maybe wrong ears and
it's not handsome and here's where we
get to blame Tolkien for making the elf
so handsome that all of the race
possibilities are described by the
length of their ears and whether or not
they meet the Legolas standard
snow is important it's like there's a
reason this happened like I was supposed
to find him hey my plea to my parents
when bringing home a scroungy mutt dog
rescue when I was a kid somehow makes
its way into a billion dollar budget
show
now we know that irondir has no manners
by not knocking before entering a
stranger's house
[Music]
why are you giving him your Lantern his
torch is right down there and still lit
and you're gonna need light on the way
back I guess we're skipping right on
over the trip from here to there I don't
mind that especially if nothing
interesting happened but this must have
taken so long and they only have until
spring and if they wrote giant Birds
show us also these two show up in the
same [__] clothes as if elves managed
to not get Road worn than if they rode
over on horses then changed back into
nice clothes where's their Entourage
where's their Camp how did they get here
so [__] fast in such perfect
condition they they sculpt The Rock
with the respect of one who cares for an
aged parent if a child of mine
approached me in my old age with a
chisel and Hammer asking to sculpt me
I'd wonder where I went wrong she don't
ever explains how any of the dwarves
aren't blind from this massive mirror
reflecting the [__] Sun through their
skulls it's hard to believe that an
event like this would draw so few
Dwarven folks to view it this is an elf
that is wrong the prince showing up to
throw down in a rock smashing challenge
this cozy Tavern should be packed
where's the arena for this epic event
dude that's Boulder number one in an
endurance match maybe cool it on the
premature celebration a quick question
about the dental hygiene of the Comet
people do they not have a sort of
celestial health care package or
something seems like a real gig to be
hurled to a planet and immediately
suffer from mental distress
disorientation zero language skills and
rotting teeth the French
middle management where do you belong
where are all the others you know if
you're kind like you nor has already
realized that Comet person has no memory
and can't talk yet she continues to ask
complex questions rather than Advance
him from the what to put in mouth stage
to the where to go potty stage baby
steps are called baby steps for a reason
questions about the meaning of life can
wait until the diapered man knows how to
Google gaga
holy sh that comment man did some weird
stuff with a stick in the mud and Nori's
father's ankle broke did he make it
happen was it foretold in the stars that
this must be the way in order for the
comet man to fold into the story and he
was warning Nori of the danger who knows
this episode is fully embracing the idea
that every scene with him is a massive
dose of magical Intrigue hope and a
horrific sense of danger stop [__]
with me and tell me who this is our next
clue is the common man is excellent at
creating pants from the camouflage Moss
fabric that Nori brought from their
campsite come to think of it Nori
grabbed a hobbit-sized piece of fabric
earlier but that's not nearly enough to
cover Comet man so he is also great at
creating something from nothing you saw
him
way to relief on that leg much less pull
a car find your own fire mother Well
normally we send kids but this one
actually did something right by telling
this crusty old gossip where she can
shove her opinions so I guess this is
for malva stop being such a hag if
you're so concerned about their cart
offer to help pull it yourself we now
interrupt your exciting Lord of the
Rings series to return to a marathon
session of Galadriel Phelps because when
I thought of second age Galadriel I know
long distance swimming was the first
image that came to mind you liar what
exactly did she lie about all she's told
you so far she was separated from her
ship which is technically true I mean
it's definitely Fey word games but she
hasn't lied to you
show gives the boat people in the sweet
sea worm the NPC treatment of an
experienced DM and kills the encounter
quickly so that the players aren't
diverted from the main storyline for
longer than necessary we want more worm
my tears may be the blink of an itunlf
but I've lived an entire life in that
time Well Ron apparently went to the
dream School of catching up with friends
so sure they're technically already
indoors because they're underground but
you still shut the front door to houses
elrond for smooth talking Elf you sure
are showing that you're also kind of a
dick make yourself comfortable please
but not too comfortable
okay the highlight of this episode is
absolutely elrond in Duran reconnecting
The Sassy way that they do I'm impressed
with nearly every part of what I'm
seeing on screen from the writing set
design for static CGI Direction all of
it's beautifully done in these scenes
but you need the great acting to bring
these vibrant characters to life and I'm
glad to actually enjoy myself turns my
spirit animal that is until he showed up
at our next survey I'm the one after
that and the one after that always did
have a talent for lurking the elvish
word for stalking is apparently lurking
and honestly Tolkien should have
foreseen the confusion this would bring
[Music]
gotta love that dramatically timed
Thunder it's never late nor early it
booms precisely when it means to set
designers decide to smash our dreams and
answer the question why not fly
everywhere on the big glorious Birds by
showing us a terrifying depiction of
birds devouring people it was as if the
grounds were swallowed up the people of
ordered like flies how how would the
crown swallow people up like flies great
now for the rest of the show I'll be
imagining how this analogy works at all
the hordon folk buzzing around like
flies over in the earth gobbling them it
doesn't make sense we must spread the
word no I will not have this gossip
Bronwyn I've seen landslides less
dangerous than I we would have told them
without proof or pudding
that's all it would be okay first of all
with more than one person present in the
tavern in this small town the landslide
of Gossip has already begun and second
proof is found in the nearby Town's
pudding when another person confirms
bronwyn's Story by riding to the next
town why not believe her I understand
that she's the elf love and Outcast but
she's also their needed healer if she
leaves for danger or for rejection
they're in more trouble than what flies
near gobbly land it still doesn't make
sense
settle down Theo you don't know what
kind of mice you're picking a fight with
or where they're from Mom will help you
if they're from Nim smart little rodents
won't hesitate to outsmart you in your
little fire poker all right Joe I've had
my fill of what's in the darkness
tension while glateral was bobbing like
a snack at Sea now you're just wanting
to steal any sense of peace and torture
me with that will haunt my sleepy time
where are the singing elves and adorable
Hobbit says all right show I've had my
fill of how can I fit my body tightly
into the darkness while being hunted
tension and you know the rest why is
there light in this underground space
around here dropped his Lantern in the
water is there a hole above if so why
isn't around there trying to climb out
through the air this is a bad guy hand
just hanging out there like a root until
the perfect amount of tension builds up
for it to pounce if you really think
about it the orc that's attached to that
arm has the easiest job just lays around
in the dark passage where nobody really
goes being totally still like a vinyl
limpy noodle-like I bet it's a lot of
napping honestly hang on now there are
two big Windows letting in lots of
sunshine Saruman had to breed urokai
specifically to move in sunlight but
this plane work isn't bothered by all
this vitamin D
down
cool scene but no way does Theo weigh
enough to lift this orc off the ground
and suspend him for even a few seconds
he might be 40 pounds soaking wet on the
one head I'm glad Bronwyn was able to
defeat their foe but on the other head
I'm disappointed she didn't go for the
choppy head off weapon in the first
place it was an option the whole time
and she instinctively went for this
first
holy abrupt transition Batman I think I
just fell out of my chair got whiplashed
or something also Bronwyn Palms the head
basketball style is she in shock who
does that just open the Satchel carrying
the Noggin and have your peers peep in
for a look-see there's no reason for a
dramatic reveal when the head of an orc
is in and of itself a dramatic reveal we
made for the Elven Tower at first light
but not right now because I really need
to get some rest and refocus my efforts
on adding weapons to my healing house I
don't know guys really seems like an elf
would take being struck by lightning and
thrown into the sea is a sign that they
were on the wrong path or something but
I guess the show has to find a way to
make us believe that something could
stop the badass that is glad real can
anything stopper I mean I assume that
Sauron could stop her somehow wait does
Sauron live in the lightning I figured
out who Sauron is and that kids is why
you don't tie yourself to a [__] Mast
while in the ocean or really anywhere
please observe the comet creature
exampling to we the croissant people
that you can in fact uncoil the haunched
over video game posture and properly
stand the [__] up it's a lantern
we use fireflies okay but is any rural
kid who grew up catching fireflies will
tell you their asses don't stay lit
constantly these lanterns were truly
fueled by fireflies they'd be blinking
more often than not I don't speak
Firefly thing Fox executive said just
before canceling the greatest science
fiction series of all time somehow makes
it into the episode
this will he won't he foreboding feeling
centered around Comet man's good or evil
motivations it better resolve quickly
because I don't want to spend the rest
of this season popping antacids
holy sh how do the dwarfs get a hold of
a treasure chest from Marcellus Wallace
these dumbass human people had a horror
creep through their floor and they're
just hanging out how are they so certain
no other baddies are going to spill up
from the floor
I don't know Theo I wouldn't mess with a
sword that drinks blood you want to end
up like Grog just a shadow of a man that
could rescue us better go back to sleep
we'll take the horse and acid it's not
just a folders
[Music]
you sit on a throne of Lies what's he
saying to them we have cucumbers keep
swimming just keep swimming swimming
swimming
[Music]